the earnback scheme to ensure that
people from less wealthy countries are
protected against covid19
is being hailed as a historic moment
the arrival of 600 000 valves from india
mocks the beginning of a massive
campaign that will see more than 2
billion doses delivered to several
developing countries across different
continents
this covax program is about equity and
solidarity if you've
followed the vaccination going on around
the planet
so far it's only citizens from the
let us say the better off countries that
have benefited from this and from today
we're bringing equity ghana plans to
inoculate around 20
of its population in the first phase of
its campaign
but it's still not enough and the
government says it's working on securing
more doses
almost 2.5 million people worldwide have
died from coronavirus
so far rich countries have been able to
buy far more vaccines than poorer ones
and while kovacs has managed to raise
six billion dollars
it needs at least another two billion to
meet its target for 2021.
this kovacs is only financed now so we
can reach in 92 countries
the most vulnerable population the older
citizens the health workers
people with comorbidities you know but
we need
much more vaccines and financing so we
can
vaccinate everybody just like if you are
in the rich world
countries to receive the life-saving
vaccines next will include some of the
poorest countries in the world
including haiti democratic republic of
congo and afghanistan where the kovacs
programme will cover
20 percent of its 38 million population
the global race for doses has meant that
high-income countries can more easily do
deals with vaccine manufacturers than
low-income ones
so the world health organization and
unhcr are urging those companies
to prioritize contracts with kovacs and
ensure fair distribution worldwide
so far 210 million dollars of vaccine
have been administered globally
but half of those are in just two
countries
and 80 percent are in just 10 countries
more than 200 countries are yet to
administer a single dose
after a year of disruptions due to the
pandemic there's hope
that this is the beginning of the path
to recovery for those most affected
and those that are most vulnerable
al jazeera